l'air du temps l'air que nous respirons
s'il est pour lui il faut faire quelque
chose l'air du temps l'époque dans
laquelle nous vivons
alors il faut parler de notre
comportement notre comportement
parlons-en
c'est notre envie effrénée de mobilité
de vouloir être à la fois à la ville à
la campagne à la mer c'est la société de
consommation c'est les montagnes de
déchets c'est le gaspillage alimentaire
et c'est tout à fait dans l'air du temps
rien que cette semaine fermeture de
fessenheim
ouverture du salon de l'agriculture et
l'économie mondiale qui ralentit quand
une nouvelle forme de grippe a à la
chine
alors il faut trouver le lien le lien
entre l'environnement l'énergie les
transports l'agriculture et ses millions
de tonnes de co2 qui partent dans
l'atmosphère alors moi dans tout ça
j'étais mal parti je suis parti en
australie pour construire des mines de
charbon je suis parti en allemagne
construire des usines pour l'automobile
je suis parti aux états unis
vendre des milliers de t-shirts à 99
cents non j'étais vraiment mal parti
mais j'ai changé et je suis allé dans le
monde du transport public
vous savez c'est les autobus les
autocars c'est hyper pratique très
efficace et puis en même temps ça nous
ramène un petit peu à l'enfance ça nous
ramène au moment où on prenait le car
pour aller au collège
on partait en excursion on partait en
colonie de vacances
on nous ont mené en classe verte allez
découvrir les fermes
on nous expliquait que finalement le
fumier n'était pas sale puisqu'ils
retourner sur les terres pour nourrir
les champs on allait aussi en forêt nous
expliquer la photosynthèse
vous savez produire de l'oxygène
capturer du co2 grâce au soleil
finalement c'est l'histoire de
l'humanité c'est comme ça qu'on a fait
pousser nos légumes nos fruits c'est
comme ça que nos troupeaux ont pu aller
se nourrir dans les pâturages mais c'est
aussi l'histoire des forêts primaires
et les forêts primaires ce sont elles
qui sur des millions d'années ont
capturé ce au cox carbone qui est
maintenant stocké sous forme de pétrole
et de charbon sous la terre alors
forcément si on 200 ans d'ère
industrielle on le libère dans
l'atmosphère ça peut avoir un effet la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on peut enrayer
ce cercle vicieux
je vais vous donner une méthode la
méthode ça serait de valoriser les
déchets organiques
on l'aimé tamisant les collecter les
emmener dans un méthaniseur pour en
faire une énergie comment ça fonctionne
c'est assez simple c'est plus ou moins
un gros estomac de vache qui en un mois
va digérer toute cette matière pour le
transformer en méthane ce fameux biogaz
qu'on va pouvoir utiliser comme énergie
décarbonée - le principe de base
alors pour ça il va falloir travail
travailler sur l'individu comme
travailler sur le collectif et
l'individuel nous une nouvelle fois
c'est notre comportement et le collectif
c'est à la fois des technologies essai
de l'organisation exemple la cuisine
chez soi trions nos déchets premièrement
trion les déchets pour qu'ils puissent
aller dans les méthaniseurs par contre
pour avoir du volume c'est là où on a la
restauration collective les supermarchés
qui génère des quantités de déchets
c'est là où se trouve ce gaspillage
alimentaire récoltons le il ya déjà des
start up qui se monte pour gérer cette
logistique
alors vous comprenez bien qu'ici à lyon
dans notre ville de taille moyenne 1
million d'habitants on peut le faire
mais pensez aux mets aux mégalopoles
métropole qui sont de l'autre côté de la
planète
penser qu'on construit chaque année
l'équivalent de manhattan en taille en
building en population et là forcément
ce sont des ressources colossales
il faut les récupérer il faut les trier
parce que sinon c'est une double peine
la pollution des eaux la pollution de
l'air ce sont des quantités
astronomiques
imaginer qu'avec sept mille habitants
ont produit suffisamment de bio déchets
pour alimenter un autobus en biogaz
pendant toute l'année
génial non alors ça c'est pour le ces
pour la ville à londres du côté du rural
avec les fermes alors c'est
l'agriculture mais je vais pas vous
demander d'aller planter des céréales
pour après les méthaniser pour faire du
biogaz ça c'est stupide c'est totalement
contraire à l'idée de l'alimentation ce
que je veux dire c'est qu'on va
récupérer et on le récupère aujourd'hui
tous les déchets organiques
une fois encore pour les emmener au
méthaniseur est juste à proximité
c'est l'industrie agroalimentaire les
laiteries les conserveries l'industrie
sucrière qui utilise de la betterave
je suis allé visiter d'ailleurs il ya
deux mois un méthaniseur qui fonctionne
avec la pulpe de betterave
une fois qu'on a finalement obtenu le
sucre alors ça c'est génial parce que
ces déchets là ont une valeur
énergétique directement disponibles
c'est aussi très intéressant au niveau
de l'agriculture puisque c'est aussi on
va parler de la ghriba chine en ce
moment c'est le salon de l'agriculture
tout ce que font les airs et culture
c'est mauvais et là forcément c'est une
nouvelle manière d'appréhender la terre
une nouvelle manière de s'organiser de
mutualiser ces déchets d'investir dans
des méthaniseurs et finalement d'avoir
une meilleure approche de la valeur du
sol
alors on est là en train de vous
expliquer finalement ce qu'est ce cercle
vertueux du biométhane je collecte les
déchets je l'aimais tanis je crée un
biogaz que j'injecte dans les réseaux et
finalement il va servir à la mobilité
donc une mobilité décarbonée pour les
autobus et des autocars pour les camions
bennes à ordures ménagères pour les
transports de la logistique et même les
voitures particulières
non seulement c'est une mobilité bas
carbone mais aussi en terme d' analyse
du cycle de vie
cet excellent et c'est la plus abordable
pas d'énergie fossile pas de lithium pas
de production de déchets radiotoxiques
cet excellent mais il ya un deuxième
effet que le second effet bénéfique
second cercle vertueux c'est que ce
qu'on le récupère à la sortie du
méthaniseur mais finalement c'est du
compost et se compose qu'est ce que
c'est c'est un engrais naturel un
fertilisant du sol qui finalement
retourne sur les terres agricoles alors
en ville qu'est ce que c'est c'est les
espaces verts ça peut être
l'horticulture et sur les terres rurales
passe effectivement contribué à jerry
lisez les sols et du coup réduire la
quantité de produits phytosanitaires
qu'on va utiliser donc cet excellent cet
excellent parce que vous avez compris
on va pouvoir lutter contre la pollution
lutter contre les gaz à effet de serre
on va en même temps produire une énergie
locale
on va créer des emplois ici chez nous
tout en étant avec une énergie
décarbonée
au final vous voyez c'est une nouvelle
ère une ère plus responsable et qui nous
inscrit pleinement dans l'histoire de
l'humanité depuis les forêts primaires
jusqu'aux mégalopole d'aujourd'hui et
c'est un air plus propre
un petit peu comme l'air con aller
respirer à la campagne quand on allait
dans les classes vertes
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]